[Musique]
et c'est avec Anthony Saint Léger
bonsoir Anthony bonsoir Audrey on va
reparler de la cop27 et on s'intéresse à
une théorie phare du complotisme
climatique vieille de plusieurs
décennies mais ce ne sont pas allés
kentrails mais c'est parfois lié il
s'agit du harpe C cinq lettres sur
lesquels je reviendrai un petit peu plus
tard plus tard pour la signification
d'abord on va s'intéresser et montrer à
quel point cette théorie est encore
d'actualité il y a quelques heures il y
a eu ce tweet de l'OMC l'organisme l'OMS
pardon l'Organisation Mondiale de la
Santé qui évoquait qui mettait en garde
contre les dangers provoqués par des
événements
météorologiques extrêmes en raison de
cette crise climatique ce à quoi ont
répondu certains internautes savez-vous
aussi à quoi c'est dû au harpe justement
et à la géo ingénierie on y reviendra là
encore plus tard de même aux
déclarations assez alarmiste du
secrétaire général de l'ONU Antonio
guteres qui parle d'une autoroute qui
mène vers l'enfer climatique certains
ont répondu somme nous prêts pour la
nouvelle arnaque covid d'évoquer ce
hashtag harpe dont il était question
dans le précédent tweet et d'évoquer
aussi le changement climatique comme ni
plus ni moins qu'une infox alors est-ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce que
signifie ces cinq lettres et bien oui
fini le suspense donc
HAARP pour high frequency Activ oral oui
search a progrès programme en deux mots
il s'agit d'un programme de recherche
qui a été financé par l'armée américaine
écrit dans les années 90 l'armée
américaine s'est retirée depuis 2014 et
depuis et bien c'est l'université de
Fairbanks en Alaska qui sont nos cubes
le but c'est d'étudier l'ionosphère
c'est-à-dire la couche supérieure de
l'atmosphère qui est située entre 60 et
1000 km de hauteur et pour ce faire et
bien ce programme dispose
du nœud de 200 antennes à eau à eau à
haute fréquence déployée sur une
quinzaine d'hectares à gaconat donc
c'est en Alaska c'est le point rouge que
l'on voit ici et on voit ce champ
d'antenne et c'est une technologie assez
complexe et parce que justement elle est
assez difficile à comprendre pour les
néophytes et bien elle génère depuis de
nombreuses années de nombreux fantasmes
de nombreuses infox exemple par exemple
justement
elle a été harpe a été imputé par
exemple à
l'ouragan Katrina plutôt en 2005 aux
États-Unis a été imputé à harpe de même
que le séisme de Fukushima en 2011 au
Japon et puis il y a eu aussi de
nombreuses images détournées qui ont
cherché à considérer harp comme une arme
cachée une arme météorologique cachée
dans le but de modifier le climat par
exemple
regardez ce twito d'un internaute qui
publie ses images et qui évoque une
machine à nuage faite de harpe là où on
se fait il s'agit tout simplement d'un
test de moteur de fusée de la part de la
NASA on la prend par exemple via la
revue scientifique américaine de verge
un autre exemple qui nous amène cette
fois-ci au Brésil via cette vidéo que
l'on va découvrir ensemble on y voit des
personnes assez en colère qui détruit
justement des antennes et les
internautes qui les parent qui partagent
cette vidéo d'affirmer qu'il s'agit de
Brésiliens en colère qui détruisent
précisément ces antennes harpes dans la
forêt amazonait amazonienne là où la
réalité est un petit peu plus précise il
s'agit bien de Brésiliens en colère
effectivement mais qui détruisent de
simples installations électriques lors
d'une révolte dans une ferme au Brésil
certes en 2017 mais l'idée de prendre le
contrôle sur la météo n'est pas sûr
d'Antony effectivement puisque que ce
soit la Chine les États-Unis ou encore
la Russie ils se sont déjà penchés sur
la question et notamment en essayant de
créer de la pluie ou de disperser du
brouillard mais à courte échelle pour
vous donner un exemple pour que harpe
est vraiment un impact sur l'atmosphère
à grande échelle il faudrait que ça ait
la puissance d'une bombe atomique c'est
vous dire pour ce qui est de l'écho
ingénierie dont je parlais tout à
l'heure il s'agit là de modifier le
climat à plus grande échelle et c'est
une piste pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique par exemple en
envoyant des particules dans le ciel
dans le but de bloquer la lumière l'idée
de créer une sorte de nuage de poussière
un peu à l'image de ce qui se passe
lorsqu'il y a une éruption Vulcan
volcanique entre un écran donc entre le
Soleil et la Terre pour créer une sorte
de rafraîchissement mais ce n'est qu'un
projet et les résultats sont pour leur
pas très probants merci beaucoup Anthony
Saint-Léger vous restez avec nous on se
retrouve dans quelques instants pour un
nouveau journal
[Musique]